ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA BARRICADE HIM SENATE
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BURKE
CALDERON RIO CERVANTES CHAU
CHEN CHIU CHOI COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEAD.
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE REBAJAS
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH.
STONE CHANGE BALLADARES VIA
PODA VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WICKS
WORD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS OF
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER THE
DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM YES
YOUR CON. YOU MONEY FAIR. IN
THE NAME OF GOD. THE MOST
GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL.
ALMIGHTY GOD. FOR THIS NEW DAY
WITH ITS PROMISE AND POTENTIAL
WE THANK YOU. MAY OUR PARK AND
THIS DAY BE FULL OF MEANING AND
HOPE. FOR OTHERS MAY OUR
EFFORTS AND OUR WORDS BE
CHARACTERIZED BY KINDNESS. AND
GIVE EXPRESSION TO THE GOODWILL
AND FRUIT THAT IS WITHIN US.
MAY DAY ALSO BE THE KEY WHICH
UNLOCKS THE GOOD AND TRUTH IN
OTHERS I MEAN. THANK YOU WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SNAPPED AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE PLEASE
PLACE YOUR HAND OVER YOUR HEART
AS WE HONOR OUR FLAG OF OUR
NATION READY BEGIN. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. AND
TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU YOU
MAY BE SEATED. MOVING TO THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SACRAMENTO TUESDAY JANUARY
TWENTY SIXTH RASMUSSEN MISTER
FLORES SECOND FOR THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
BE DISPENSED WITH. INTIMATIONS
OF PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL. MITHRAS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW THE
SPEAKER AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
CRISTINA GARCIA BY THE ARTISTS
AND MEDINA TO SPEAK ON
ADJOURNMENT AND MEMORY TODAY.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. MOVING
TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
WE WILL PASS ND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM ONE MOVING TO FILE ITEM TO
ACR TWENTY THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY BY SOME REMEMBER MEDINA
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
FINANCIAL AID AWARENESS MONTH.
MR MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I AM PLEASED TO INTRODUCE ACR
TWENTY WITH MY COLLEAGUES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY.
FEBRUARY IS RECOGNIZED
NATIONALLY AS FINANCIAL AID
AWARENESS MONTH. DURING WHICH
EDUCATORS ADVOCATES AND THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION REMIND STUDENTS TO
APPLY FOR FINANCIAL AID BY THE
MARCH SECOND DEADLINE. THE
IMPORTANCE OF FINANCIAL AID TO
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS CANNOT BE
OVERSTATED. FOR MANY CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
ACCESS TO FINANCIAL AID IS THE
SINGLE DETERMINING FACTOR
BETWEEN CHOOSING TO PURSUE
HIGHER EDUCATION OR NOT.
ESPECIALLY FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF COLOR.
NOW MORE THAN EVER STUDENTS
WITHIN EVERY POCKET OF
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM ARE STRUGGLING TO GET BY.
FROM THE COST OF TUITION
SUPPORTING THEIR FAMILIES BASIC
NEEDS SUCH AS FOOD HOUSING AND
THE INTERNET. HOWEVER FINANCIAL
AID IS STILL AVAILABLE FOR THE
STUDENTS. WHETHER A STUDENT IS
ATTENDING A BACHELOR'S
88 DEGREES CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAM THERE'S MONEY
AVAILABLE FOR HELP. THESE LANDS
ARE STILL AVAILABLE FOR
STUDENTS TAKING THEIR COURSES
ONLINE AS A RESULT OF CLOTHING
NINETEEN CAMPUS CLOSURES. THE
FASTER THE CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATION ARE THE TWO PRIMARY
APPLICATIONS THAT STUDENTS CAN
USE TO APPLY FOR FINANCIAL AID.
THE FASTER IT IS USED TO APPLY
FOR STATE FINANCIAL AID. LIKE
THE CAL GRANT. THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP FEDERAL FINANCIAL
GRANT. AN INSTITUTIONAL EIGHT
LIKE THE BLUE AND GOLD
SCHOLARSHIP FOR THE STATE
UNIVERSITY GRAD. UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS WHO MADE AB FIVE FORTY
REQUIREMENTS COULD FILE A CATA
TO APPLY FOR STATE FINANCIAL
AID AN INSTITUTIONAL AID AS
WELL. MARCH SECOND IS THE
PRIORITY DEADLINE FOR STATE
FINANCIAL AID INCLUDING THE
PELL GRANT FOR MOST STUDENTS.
WELL COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
HAVE UNTIL SEPTEMBER SECOND FOR
THE SECOND FOR THE COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT PROGRAMS. AT A TIME
WHEN CALIFORNIA'S READS AMIN
ITS FINANCIAL AID STRUCTURE. IS
MORE THAN APPROPRIATE THAT THE
MONTH THIS MONTH WE DECLARE
FINANCIAL AID WHERE AWARENESS
MONTH. I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THE INVESTMENT IN THE FUTURE OF
OUR STATE. AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
MEDINA. SEEING AND HEARING NO
OTHER TO. MISTER TROY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR CHAMBER
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ALL ARE
YOU STAND UP IN SUPPORT ALL OF
OUR AC ON TWENTY- BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF MEDINA AS- VICE CHAIR
OF THE HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. I STRONGLY URGE ALL
TV OFF PEOPLE ARE YOUNG
STUDENTS TO BE AWARE OF ALL THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THIS COUNTRY
HAS TO OFFER FOR THE
SCHOLARSHIPS ARE NOT ONLY OUT
THROUGH FEDERAL GRANTS BUT THE
STATE. PRIVATE AND US ALL MANY
UPPER. IN THIS COUNTRY WE ALL
FOR THE SCHOLARSHIPS SINCE THE
WE BELIEVE IN EDUCATION.
EDUCATION IS SUCH AS TO ALL
KNOWN AS SO. FOUNDATION FOR
SUCCESS WHEN I SPOKE TO MY-
WELL ALUMNI UNIVERSITY OF.
PITTSBURGH A DISTINGUISHED
ALUMNI SPEECH THAT I SAID TO MY
PHD. WAS A GATEWAY TO A
POLITICS IT FOR ANYONE IS
INTERESTED IN. POLITICS STUDY
HARD TO ACHIEVE YOUR HIGH YOUR
DEGREE. WE THOUGHT MIAMI HIGHER
DEGREE I SAID ANYONE. I
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN INVITED TO
TEACH AT THE UNIVERSITY OF A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA UPON
COMPLETION OF MY PHD DEGREE
JUST BECAUSE OF A MINE.
EXPERIENCE IN TEACHING. PEOPLE
IN MY COMMUNITY ENCOURAGED ME
STEVE ON RUN FOR SCHOOL BOARD
RUN FOR SCHOOL BOARD. IT'S OUR
PROGRAM FOR TWO YEARS TO
CONVINCE ME TO RUN. FINALLY
AFTER TWO YEARS- I RENTAL
SCHOOL BOARD THAT WAS MY FIRST
STEP TOWARD THE POLITICS AND-
HE IBM. AND THE REPRESENTING MY
DISTRICT SIXTY EIGHT AND THE
ENTIRE- STATE. LEGISLATING
IMPORTANT ISSUES SO- THIS IS
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS SO TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
IN YOUR DISTRICT ALL THE
STUDENTS ARE WHO ARE IN NEED OF
A FINANCIAL AID. TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF. OUR OPPORTUNITIES
EVEN MY SISTER WHO IS A MEDICAL
DOCTOR RIGHT NOW SHE DIDN'T
HAVE ANY PENDING I WASN'T NOT
ABLE TO AFFORD TO HAVE MEDICAL
SCORES. BUT DAHLE SHE FINISHED.
OUR MEDICAL SCHOOL EDUCATION-
WITH THE ALL THE SCHOLARSHIPS
AND NOT JUST BECAUSE SEARCHES.
TO SERVING. INDIA AND COMMUNITY.
HER ORDERED SO BE FOR GIVE.
THERE ARE SO MANY OPPORTUNITIES
IN THIS. AND EDUCATION IS UPON.
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO SUCCEED I-
DO YOU YOU ACCEPT THE WHOLE ARE
TWENTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHOI. MISTER SEA AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER IS TO ME DO YOU KNOW
WHAT. MISTER EDITOR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL AND THE FIRST ROLE
WOULD YOU LIKE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHOR SIR YEAH THANK YOU FOR
ROLE BE OPEN CO AUTHOR. THIRTY
WILL OPEN THE- ALL MEMBERS. ON
MEMBERSTO THEIR TO VOTE IT'S
IS FOR CO OP. ON EIGHTH TWENTY.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY BOTH
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED VERY BAD THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. WHERE TWELVE
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THOUGH
THERE ARE SIXTY ONE CO AUTHORS
UNEASY OR TWENTY WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION ALL IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. I'LL POST SAY NO
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. MOVING TO FILE ITEM
THREE HR TWENTY TO THE CLERK
WILL READ. HOUSE RESOLUTION
TWENTY TWO BY SOME REMEMBER
MURATSUCHI AND OTHERS RELATIVES
JAPANESE AMERICAN CONCENTRATION
CAMPS. MURATSUCHI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR CHAMBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MEMBERS
EVERY YEAR JAPANESE AMERICANS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY GATHER FOR A
DAY OF REMEMBRANCE. TOMORROW
FEBRUARY NINETEENTH IT'S A
SEVENTY NINTH ANNIVERSARY AT
THE DAY THAT PRESIDENT FRANKLIN
ROOSEVELT. ISSUED EXECUTIVE
ORDER NINE ZERO SIX SIX. WHICH
LED. WHICH LED TO THE REMOVAL
AND INCARCERATION OF OVER ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
JAPANESE AMERICANS SOLELY
BECAUSE OF THEIR RACE WITHOUT
ANY DUE PROCESS OF LAW. AND
WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE OF TREASON
OR ACTUAL MILITARY NECESSITY.
SO IT IS FOR THIS REASON THAT
JAPANESE AMERICANS GATHER. FOR
THIS DAY OF REMEMBRANCE. TO
REMEMBER THIS DAY OF INFAMY.
EVEN THOUGH THEY HAD NOTHING TO
DO WITH PEARL HARBOR THEY LOST
THEIR HOMES. THEY LOST THEIR
FARMS THEY LOST THEIR
BUSINESSES. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THEY LOST THEIR
FREEDOM. DECADES AFTER THE WAR
STARTING IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES. INSPIRED BY THE BLACK
COMMUNITY'S FIGHT FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS. JAPANESE AMERICANS
BEGAN TO ORGANIZE A GRASSROOTS
NATIONAL MOVEMENT FOR
REPARATIONS. THEY FOUGHT FOR
CONGRESS TO CREATE A COMMISSION.
THE STUDY THE ISSUE OF
REPARATIONS FOR THE WARTIME
INCARCERATION OF JAPANESE
AMERICANS. AND THAT
COMMISSION'S REPORT. TOGETHER
WITH DECADES OF EDUCATING AND
ORGANIZING LED TO PRESIDENT
RONALD REAGAN SIGNING THE CIVIL
LIBERTIES ACT OF NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT. A HISTORIC CIVIL
RIGHTS BILL WHICH PROVIDED
REPARATIONS AND AN APOLOGY ON
BEHALF OF OUR NATION TO THE
SURVIVORS OF AMERICA'S
CONCENTRATION CAMPS. KEY
LEADERS IN THIS MOVEMENT FOR
REPARATIONS INCLUDED LEGENDARY
BLACK CONGRESSMAN. RON DELLUMS
OF OAKLAND. AND JOHN CONYERS OF
MICHIGAN. WHO FOR DECADES
FOUGHT TO CREATE A SIMILAR
COMMISSION. THE STUDY THE ISSUE
OF REPARATIONS FOR SLAVERY AND
THE LEGACY OF SLAVERY IN
AMERICA. TODAY THERE'S AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION TAKING
PLACE IN OUR CONGRESS FOR THIS
SAME COMMISSION TO STUDY THE
ISSUE OF REPARATIONS FOR
SLAVERY. JAPANESE AMERICANS OWE
A DEBT OF GRATITUDE TO THE
BLACK COMMUNITY FOR LEADING THE
FIGHT. FOR REPARATIONS FOR
JAPANESE AMERICANS THAT IS WHY
MANY JAPANESE AMERICANS
INCLUDING MYSELF ARE STANDING
UP TO SUPPORT THE ONGOING BLACK
STRUGGLE FOR REPARATIONS AND TO
SUPPORT HOUSE RESOLUTION FORTY
EIGHT CONGRESSIONAL RESOLUTION
TO CREATE. A COMMISSION ON
REPARATIONS FOR SLAVERY.
MEMBERS ARE PRESENT THIS
RESOLUTION TO DECLARE FEBRUARY.
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS A
DAY OF REMEMBRANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER MURATSUCHI MISTER BLOOM
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE AND
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE MEMBER
FROM TORRANCE FOR HIS
CONSISTENT EFFORTS TO ENSURE
THAT WE NEVER FORGET THIS VERY
DARK MOMENT. IN OUR COUNTRY'S
HISTORY. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT THE FEDERAL CIVIL
LIBERTIES ACT WAS ENACTED. AND
IN THAT ACT CONGRESS RECOGNIZE
THE JAPANESE AMERICAN
INCARCERATION IN CAMPS DURING
WORLD WAR TWO WAS QUOTE
MOTIVATED LARGELY BY RACIAL
PREJUDICE WARTIME HYSTERIA AND
A AILURE. OF POLITICAL
LEADERSHIP AND QUOTE. I WAS
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AND I
THINK THAT WE SHOULD REFLECT ON
THOSE WORDS NOW THIRTY TWO
YEARS AFTER THEY WERE WRITTEN
AND- WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
WE STILL HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO
TO ADDRESS THE RACIAL PREJUDICE
THAT PERSISTS IN OUR COUNTRY.
EARLIER THIS WEEK WE VOTED ON A
MEASURE TO DENOUNCE THE
DRAMATIC INCREASE IN HATE
CRIMES THAT WE HAVE SEEN
PERPETRATED AGAINST API'S IN
OUR STATE. AND THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY. WE MUST NEVER FORGET
OUR HISTORY ESPECIALLY THE
DARKEST MOMENTS AND AS I SAID.
EARLIER THIS WEEK WE MUST SHINE
A LIGHT ON THESE ISSUES AND
LEARN FROM OUR MOST PROFOUND
MISTAKES. I ASK WERE AYE VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU MR
GRAMM. HEARING IN HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISTER MURATSUCHI WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I ASKED FOR THE FIRST ROLE
TO BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS AND I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THE CLERK WHAT THE
FIRST ROLL OF THE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS THE THIRD WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
HR TWENTY TWO. HOME MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. SMALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE THERE ARE
SIXTY TWO CO AUTHORS ON HR
TWENTY TWO WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NO THE AYES
HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE SECOND DAY CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEMS FOUR AND
FIVE. THERE IS A RESOLUTION ON
TODAY'S CONSENT CALENDAR BEFORE
WE VOTE ON THE CONTENT CALENDAR
WE WILL FIRST TAKE UP THE
RESOLUTION THAT IS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR PURPOSES
ADDING CO AUTHORS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE ONE ROLL
CALL VOTE AND ALLOW ANY MEMBER
TO ADD ON IS A CO AUTHOR TO THE
RESOLUTION. THE CLERK WILL READ
THE RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTEEN BY SIN
REMEMBER THREE OF US RELATIVE
TO ENGINEERS WEEK SOMETHING
CURRENT RESOLUTION TWENTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON
RELATIVE NATIONAL CAREGIVERS
DAY. WELL OPEN THE ROLE TO
ALLOW MEMBERS ADAM. ABSOLUTION
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DO THEIR TO
VOTE THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERITY VOTES.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS FOR THE
RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY SIX CO
AUTHORS. THE CLERK WILL BUY THE
VOTES THE RESOLUTIONS ON
TODAY'S CONSENT CALENDAR. NOW
WILL MOVE TO A VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR DO ANY MEMBERS
WISH TO MOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING
HEARING AND THE CLERK WILL READ
THE SECOND A CONTENT CALENDAR
ASSUMING THE CURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US RELATIVE TO
ENGINEERS WEEK. CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG. HOME MEMBERS VOTED
VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
VERY VOCAL. OUR MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. WHERE
TWELVE CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
BURKE WILL READ THEIR MEETING
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY EIGHT I. FIFTY SIX ZERO
ZERO. IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL WILL
NOW BE LIFTED WE WILL MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS THE QUORUM CALL HAS
BEEN LIFTED WE ASK THAT YOU
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON THESE ADORNMENTS IN
MEMORY. MEMBERS. I ASK FOR YOUR
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION. MISTER
SPEAKER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO ASK THAT THE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF
WHOSE NAY SOLEIL. OUTSIDE OF
THE AREA SURROUNDINGDAHLE IT
MAY NOT BE WELL KNOWN THAT THE
CITY IS A CENTER OF LEBANESE
COMMUNITY AND CULTURE. HUSNI
SOLEIL IS A BIG REASON FOR THAT.
HE AND HIS WIFE ARRIVED IN THE
AREA FROM HIS NATIVE LEBANON
FORTY SEVEN YEARS AGO. HE CAME
LIKE MANY IMMIGRANTS WITH
LITTLE MONEY AND WITH LITTLE
GRASP OF ENGLISH. LIKE MANY
IMMIGRANTS WHO WORKED HARD
SELLING ELECTRONICS STORE TO
DOOR HOLDING DOWN AT A SPACE AT
THE LOCAL SWAP MEET. AND
OPENING HIS OWN BUSINESS
LOCATIONS FIRST AND PARAMOUNT
AND THEN IN DOWNTOWN LOS
ANGELES. OUR COMMUNITY KNOWS
HIM FOR MORE THAN HIS
ENTREPRENEURIAL SIDE- SPACE
AWAY WAS ONE OF THE FIRST
LEBANESE TO ARRIVE IN THE AREA.
HE HELPED TO ORGANIZE AND
PURCHASE A MOSQUE IN BELL.
LATER HE WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
THE PURCHASE OF AL AL HUSAYN
COMMUNITY CENTER WHICH IS
BENEFITTED OUR LEBANESE MUSLIM
RESIDENTS AND MANY OTHERS. THAT
HUSSEIN CENTER IS- THAT FOR MY
DISTRICT OFFICE IT'S WHERE WE
DO ALL OF OUR- ARE IN
IMMIGRATION AFFAIRS ARE
NONPROFIT WORKSHOPS. OUR LEGAL
AFFAIRS VERY IMPORTANT. PART OF
OUR COMMUNITY. THERE'S MUCH TO
SAY ABOUT WHOSE NAY SOLEIL
ABOUT HIS LOVE FOR HIS CHILDREN
AND GRANDCHILDREN. ABOUT HIS
PASSION FOR HAVING HIS HANDS IN
THE SOIL TO GROW FRUIT AND
OLIVES. ABOUT HIS COMMITMENT TO
BEING A RESPECTED RESPECTED
CITIZEN. AND GIVING BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY. THAT COMMITMENT HAS
BEEN TAKEN UP BY THE NEXT
GENERATION INCLUDING HIS SON.
LISA LAY THE MAYOR VAL. WHO
SPACE AWAY DIED FEBRUARY
SECOND. HE WOULD HAVE BEEN
SEVENTY THREE YEARS OLD LAST
WEEK FEBRUARY TENTH. HE IS OR
WHAT SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
TERESA. HIS SON'S EARLY
MOHAMMED AND HUSSEIN AND BY
NINE GRANDCHILDREN. I ASK THAT
WE ADJOURNED TODAY IN THE
MEMORY OF WHOSE NAME SELECT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I
FEAR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED BENEFIT
YOUR MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I TO ISOLATED DURING
THE MEMORY OF HUSNI SAID LAST
FROM THE CITY OF AL. WHOSE NAME
WAS BORN IN LEBANON ON FEBRUARY
TENTH NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT AND
DEPARTED THIS EARTH ON FEBRUARY
SECOND. IF THERE'S A LIMIT THE
LOVER'S LIFE AND MARRY HER ON
SEPTEMBER TWENTY THIRD NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE IN LEBANON. THE
FOLLOWING MARCH THE IMMIGRATED
TO THE UNITED STATES ANY
SETTLED IN THE CITY OF BELL.
PEOPLE ALWAYS ASK ME I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF KNOWING HIM
PERSONALLY. PEOPLE ALWAYS ASK
ME HOW. HE LANDED ABOUT. AND
THAT'S NOT ALWAYS CLEAR BUT
IT'S CLEAR THAT BY WITH HIS
HOME AND HE LOVED IT. ANY PART
OF THAT LOVE TO ALL HIS FAMILY
AND NEIGHBORS OUT THERE. HE DID
HELP START THE ONLY THING
CENTER THAT IS NOT JUST A SPACE
FOR THE LEBANESE COMMUNITY CAN
PATHER. BUT HIS FAITH REALLY
LACKING ON THE LEBANESE
COMMUNITY TO COME TOGETHER.
IT'S BEEN A PLACE OF ACTIVISM
IT'S BEEN A PLACE WHERE BASS I
GOT TO FIGHT. AT A DAILY BASIS
TO TURN THE CITY AROUND AND
MAKE IT TRANSPARENT AND
HONORABLE AGAIN. THIS IS A
LITTLE OF THIS FAMILY THE- HE
ALWAYS MAKE SURE. THAT HIS
FAMILY HAD EVERYTHING THEY
NEEDED FIRST. HE WAS A LOVING
GRANDFATHER HIS NINE
GRANDCHILDREN. AND HE ALWAYS
MAKE SURE THEY HAD EVERYTHING
THEY NEEDED. WHEN YOU WOULD SEE
ANY OF THESE GRANDKIDS HE WOULD
TELL THEM SHOW ME YOUR POCKETS
WITH IN YOUR POCKET. IN THE
MATTER WAS IS LIKE IT IS THAT
IS NOT ENOUGH MEN PLOT WITH IN
MY POCKET TO GIVE IT TO YOU. HE
LEFT HIS FAMILY IN THE MOST
SINCERE WAY THANK CHRISTIAN
SURE THE GIFTS WITH THE WORLD.
THIS IS ALI ALSO LOVE THE CITY
ABOUT IN THE SOUTHEAST. HE
BELIEVES THAT THIS COMMUNITY
LESS ACCEPTING AND EMBRACES
RECENT RELIGION. HE OFTEN SAID
THAT IT WAS A LUXURY TO BE ABLE
TO LEAVE AND TO LIVE IN PEACE.
AND TO BE ACCEPTED IN A
COMMUNITY. OF OTHERS. WITH
EXAMPLE OF HOW TO LIVE LIFE
WITH COMPASSION AND EMPATHY FOR
EVERYONE EVERY DAY. HE WAS THE
HARDEST WORKER THAT YOU COULD
EVER MEET BUT IT WAS ALSO THE
LIFE OF THE PARTY IN RATED
STATING IT INVENTING CELEBRATE
ANY WINS VICTORY AT ANY DAY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE- I
JOIN IN THE MEMORY OF WITH THE
SALAD THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
GARCIA. MISFIRES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR TERMINATE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF JAKE
MEDINA JAKE MEDINA WARDEN WAS A
VIBRANT YOUNG MAN WITH A BRIGHT
FUTURE- PASSED AWAY TOO SOON AT
THE YOUNG AGE OF TWENTY. JAKE
WAS DEEPLY DEVOTED TO HIS
ACADEMICS A SENIOR AT CAL POLY
SAN LUIS OBISPO JAKE WAS SET TO
GRADUATE THIS SPRING AT THE TOP
OF HIS CLASS HE MADE THE DEAN'S
LIST EACH SEMESTER OFTEN WITH
THE PERFECT FOUR POINT OH GPA
AND HE WAS A MEMBER OF THE
SIGMA PHI DELTA BETA NU CHAPTER
CAL POLY. FRATERNITY FOR
ENGINEERING STUDENTS JAKE HAD
PLANS TO CONTINUE HIS STUDIES
AFTER GRADUATION IN BERLIN. AB
ONE OF GERMANY'S FOREMOST
ENGINEERING SCHOOLS. JAKE IS
THE SON OF LEON MORGAN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SANTA
CLARITA VALLEY'S TV. AND THE
GRANDSON OF CONNIE WORDEN
ROBERTS A FOUNDING MEMBER OF
SANTA CLARITA FIRST PLANNING
COMMISSION. THE NEWS OF JAKE'S
PASSING IS HEARTBREAKING AND MY
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE WITH
HIS FAMILY AND HIS FRIENDS AT
THIS MOST DIFFICULT TIME. TO
HONOR THIS YOUNG MAN AND THOSE
WHO LOVE HIM I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF JAKE
MEDINA WARDEN. THANK YOU THINK
UNIFIED IRIS. MR MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY IN THE REAR CHAMBER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO GERMAN THE
MEMORY OF MORRIS MENDOZA.
MORRIS PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE
OF SEVENTY TWO ON JANUARY
TWENTY SIX. RIVERSIDE AND
CASABLANCA HAVE LOST A BELOVED
AND WIDELY RESPECTED COMMUNITY
ACTIVISTS TO CORONAVIRUS.
MORRIS WAS THE OLDEST OF FOUR
CHILDREN BORN TO MORRISON ROSY
MENDOZA. WHEN MORRIS WAS ONLY
TEN YEARS OLD HIS FATHER PASSED
AWAY. IT WOULD BEGIN WORK IN
THE ORANGE GROVES WHEN HE WAS
SIXTEEN TO HELP HIS MOTHER WHO
WAS A WIDOW WITH FOUR CHILDREN
TO RAISE. FIND GRADUATION FROM
RAMONA HIGH SCHOOL IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SIX. MARCH WAS DRAFTED IN
UNITED STATES ARMY. WHEN
RETURNING FROM THE ARMY MORRIS
ATTENDED RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FOR A SHORT TIME AND
THEN BEGAN WORKING FOR THE
UNITED STATES POST OFFICE FOR
THIRTY NINE YEARS. MORRIS
BECAME ACTIVE IN THE CASABLANCA
COMMUNITY IN THE EARLY NINETEEN
SEVENTIES AS A MEMBER OF THE
CASABLANCA COMMUNITY ACTION
GROUP. CASABLANCA INTERPOLATES
COMMUNITY RELATIONS COMMITTEE.
CASABLANCA PROJECT AREA
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
CASABLANCA VFW POST ONE EIGHTY
FOUR AND MOST RECENTLY AS A
MEMBER OF THE NEWLY FORMED CAG
EDUCATION ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
CITY OF RIVERSIDE NAME AND DOES
AWAY FOR ALL OF MR MENDOZA'S
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE CASABLANCA
COMMUNITY. THROUGHOUT HIS
INVOLVEMENT HE WAS ALSO HE
ALWAYS MADE TIME TO TAKE CARE
OF HIS WIFE CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN. THEY WERE HIS
FIRST PRIORITY AND HE LOVED
THEM DEARLY. MARCH WAS A PERSON
OF COMPASSION DEDICATION AND
PATIENCE. SOME WOULD CALL HIM A
PEACEMAKER A DOER AND A HERO.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF
FORTY TWO YEARS ROSY MARGARITA
MENDOZA AND THREE CHILDREN
ROUTE VICTOR AND MORRIS. FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN AND ONE GREAT
GRANDCHILD. ASKED WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF MORRIS MEN DOES.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DEATH THREE PRINT IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUEST RETURNING
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. MOVING
TO ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS PLEASE
NOTE THAT TOMORROW FEBRUARY
NINETEENTH AT FIVE PM IS THE
BILL INTRODUCTION DEADLINE. THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
FRIDAY FEBRUARY NINETEENTH NO
FLOOR SESSION- CHECK IN SESSION
MONDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY SECOND
WE WILL HAVE FLOOR SESSION AT
ONE PM. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
RETAINED ALL MOTIONS SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR BONTA MOVES AND MISTER SMITH
SECOND AT THIS HOUSE THE
INTEGER DO SO. MONDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY SECOND AT ONE PM.